Let's take a look at the results. First, 85% of those who thought they were
alone and heard choking tried to help. Next, 62% who thought they were in a
group with others when they heard the person choking tried to help. Now Darley
and Latane did many different variations of the study, and one of the main take
home findings that they found, was that, in all cases, as group size increased,
the number of people trying to help decreased. In this experiment then, when
the participants perceived that there were more people that heard the person
choking, they were less likely to help. However, when the participant thought
that they were the only one who heard the person choking, they were more likely
to help. This demonstrates the basic principle that as group size increased,
the number of people trying to help decreased.